a few years ago there was a great
cartoon I think in the new yorker where
you see some native people on the shore
and out in the harbor come the big tall
ships and one Native American says to
the other I knew that immigration policy
was something we had to work on um and
that's a little bit of a humorous
approach but my first year in teaching
in Arizona where I grew up I was
teaching in Arizona State the course
immigration law and there were Native
American students in the class and they
seriously asked all of us and taught me
to reevaluate the myths we tell
ourselves about immigration law we often
talked about the United States being
this open territory where everyone was
free to come where the land was ours for
developing and we forget that even at
the time of the founding of our country
and the first Western Europeans coming
to the United States there were
negotiations with existing people and
there were should we call the bilateral
treaties of negotiation about who could
live here and who couldn't and I think
another aspect of it is we often think
of our immigration history as two or
three paragraphs in our eighth grade
civics book you know first came Columbus
and his ships then came the Pilgrims and
each story of the first European
settlers the United States has with it
aspects of immigration limitation so for
example people coming with the Puritans
were not anyone who wanted to come there
was an application process people had to
qualify they had to be selected to the
theocracy Oh cratic leaders of the
Puritans and their religious community
and if you didn't come with the original
Puritan group and you wanted to join
later perhaps you were living in Rhode
Island and you wanted to become part of
the Puritan communities in Massachusetts
you had to apply and be vetted and
qualified much as we do with immigrants
today so tensions quickly rose in those
early religious communities about people
who were maybe the second generation not
quite as committed
to the Puritan way of life or the
mercantilism that was growing in the
Boston area and other parts of New
England that was changing the migration
patterns and so there's always been
debates about who we going to let live
next door who qualifies to come
again when we say we're talking about
immigration in the Industrial Revolution
and the agricultural revolutions before
often the story is told as just the
migration of the free labor the free
white male or the people who could come
of course part of all immigration
history in the United States is also
forced migration slavery and people
subjugated to to work here temporarily
such as indentured servants or the
convicts who were settled briefly in the
state of Georgia but the Industrial
Revolution coming to say post-civil war
that the birth of factories the greater
need for labor people moving off some of
the farms we begin to have denser
populations and cities and in increased
ability for ships to bring people from
Europe in a safer more economical method
so the great period of American rapid
immigration would we think the Ellis
Island experience right all the
Europeans that were coming the millions
of people coming at that period we often
think of that as everyone was welcome it
was all positive sure people suffered in
steerage as they were doing the passage
but once they settled in Boston or came
to Chicago or found work in Chinatown in
San Francisco it was all good but
actually there's always been great
tensions about all my creation
populations and one of the sad stories
from in my view of our histories that
organized labor early on really took the
position that it was better to be pro
integration controls and restriction
rather than working to organize the new
immigrants coming and the earliest most
grieve Grievous example is organized
labor in not today's unions but the
organized labor groups or political
groups of California opposing Chinese
migration
the California delegates to Congress
were successful in passing our first
complete immigration ban the Chinese
Exclusion acts there were several of
them between eighteen eighty and 1890s
but ultimately the motivations were
rhetoric that you here today things like
these people come to this country but
they don't want to learn our language
they don't integrate into our society
they don't go to church they will live
ten men in a room in conditions no
civilized man would live and work for
wages that no honest American would work
for so that's often stories you hear
today about China Heath or you here
today about people from Mexico and
Central and South America not it's an
unfair competition to American labor
so let's start with a proposition that
in any historical period of migration
whether we're talking about the Irish
coming in the 1830s to the 1860s we
often say the Irish came in response to
the potato famine well we can do that as
a shorthand as a sound bite but the
actual stories are much more nuanced and
in any American economic history you'll
know there are boom in bus periods so we
have the growth of the railroads the
growth of factories but there's a huge
recession in eighteen ninety three
there's a collapse of markets again
later it may be the spanish-american war
of eighteen ninety eight was in part
complicated and necessary by economic
need ellice islands at its peak in the
first 10 to 20 years of the 20th century
so 1902 1920 we had enormous recessions
post-world War one around the world so
when we think today and we think
America's in a recession some would say
depression the world's in a recession we
can't afford new immigrants they'll take
our jobs again that's a story that has a
poor truth that has been explored in
immigration policy throughout the
history of our country and all countries
it's I'm not an economist but like any
good law professor I can read the
economic literature and i can tell you
their arguments on any side so there are
economists who will say that actually
when you are in a recession having
relatively open borders or having the
ability to bring in labor and make sure
that labor is paid fair wages and we can
have debates about is that mean minimum
wage or higher adverse affected wage
actually creates economic employment
opportunity helps your country rebound
from a period of stagnation or economic
depression there's so much of the
debates that many people make to argue
against a minimum wage they say a
minimum wage actually
deters entrepreneurs from investing
because the capital risks are too high I
wouldn't go that far but I do think
there are many examples in history where
it is immigrants industry and the
willingness to start at lower wages that
has let industries develop flourish and
come back